hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to spooky's house of
jump scares or spooky's jump-scare
mansion which is coming to a close
apparently because i have only two more
demons left oh my god oh my god sorry i
forgot that you existed so there's two
more demons that i need to fight
why did you just move dull
yeah okay
all right so
i
have it's broken all right okay
wait
did i do it
wait a minute
wait did i do it
i only needed to do it once so i was
just being an idiot i mean that's
obvious but
okay all right um
unless i did something wrong but i don't
think i did anything
okay um
all right then hey doll how you doing
how are you doing
well
in that case i'm guessing that i can
go that can't be right
no way
that can't be it
no
i did something wrong i know i did
something wrong had to be something else
there's secrets in this place i know
there are i know there's secrets
i know there must be
i know
there were secrets in spookies
what about this
no
what about that weird thing that was in
the thing you remember the thing and the
thing the thing thing where was that
that wasn't back in the normal area hang
on everybody hang on hold on hold on
piano room oh why did i never know if
there's the ravens before
quarth my raven
blue
[Music]
i thought it was gonna play something
else i just feel like i'm missing
something
oh oh my god oh my god that thing that's
the thing that is the thing the thing is
that
what the
hell what the hell what was that about
you just do that on occasion
you just do that
you do that you just do that okay fine
is this how there's supposed to be
something on the wall there
what is with this room too the clicking
room
why the clicking
it's when i walk
what is that about
there's many mysteries that i have yet
to solve
and i don't appreciate any of them
what
okay i can go right through that
okay also what's with you
broken doll i don't know there's so many
things that i don't know i can't go back
that way and this way just leads to
oh yeah
this is where it was this whole west
wing i totally forgot about this area of
the house
but there was a wasn't there a shortcut
over here no
no there was not
no they must said
oh hi oh hi hold up at me
oh
so maybe if you just stay still for too
long
hey
and this place is not fun i don't like
this place
there's a tea room
how's your life essence doing
ah you're fine
you're fine
you're fine oh is your life essence a
little down there oh you're gonna get
yeah whatever
i don't need
pick her up yeah
whatever this is gonna be a whiner
i don't need it i'll heal fine
here
are you still in here
are you still in here he's gone
he's gone
okay well i don't like that
and i know that it's free now so that's
not exactly
imperative that i do any of that
also this weirdness
very disturbing problematic even
can i peek in hello peekaboo
peekaboo
okay fine let me just peek in the root
cellar one last time and if there's
anything actually important there
ah you know what no map of this area i
don't need to go back down there i don't
need to do anything i've just been
wasting a lot of time
so i'm just gonna go
boy
hi friend how are you good
i'm just going to go back i'm just going
to go back because i feel like
i must be approaching some semblance of
an ending here so i'm going to go back
stop [ __ ] around here
unless the only thing that i can think
of
that's left to do is this kind of seal
thing or the nightmare thing
so if it's a matter of just doing that
then
that's it right
this is it
isn't it
the seal chamber the seal can be turned
off but if i do this i'll have to let
the doll spirit go there's no going back
after this erase the nightmare
[Music]
why do i feel like there's something
here you know what i mean i feel like ah
you know what you know what i mean guys
you know what i mean
i think you all know what i mean
something's going on here
there's something here
i'm just not seeing it
maybe something to do with
doug rip doug
r.i.p doug nah i'm not gonna play
through that
i doubt there's anything there for me
anyway
i don't know man
i don't know
oh
what
well that's nice
that's nice
uh
ah damn you
i don't know why i'm so persistent about
this i just feel like there's something
missing
oh my god what in the hell
what's that
what
what the hell was that
ah hey stop it
what was that
was that the thing behind the bed
curtains
the bed that i couldn't see
was that behind there was that the thing
behind the bed
huh
was that the thing
ho ho
what
[Applause]
frenzy torment distorted mind blood to
spill bones to grind the flesh it takes
for time to wind eye for eye makes all
turn blind
great
good
well that's
that's the place guys just bones to
squeeze your corpse will slowly turn to
cheese
i like cheese i like cheese a lot i like
cheese a lot i really like cheese all
right let's go back there and uh
i'm gonna drop the doll off before i go
god i forget i forget i forget every
time
every time i forget i'm gonna drop the
doll off so i can fight
okay i think it was up here yeah that's
why this must be here
so i can fight right
yeah oh yeah oh yeah okay
hello
hi
hey i'll kill you
hello
oh
[Music]
do
this is some kind of a puzzle
and uh
i don't have the brain power to solve it
k doug
doug
i definitely do
it's it's probably like a letter
scramble
i'll leave it up to you guys to solve
this one
and then
if it's worth me coming back for this i
will
do something about it okay cool you guys
solve that all right good good good good
good
i don't know i don't understand but okay
so that's some kind of an easter eggy
puzzle
that's some kind of an easter eggy
puzzle but
that's really all
i don't know
i guess that's all there is
all right you know what i just been
stalling
i think there's only one thing left to
do and i better go do it
i gotta let the doll go
i have to let the doll go
i have to
it's the only thing i have left to do
also i don't know who i am in all of
this
kind of strange that i just came in here
did all this but
there's no going back after this a
recent nightmare i think isn't that that
feels like the right thing to do you
know i still don't understand
oh
oh goodbye
it was a nightmare
the night i saw the devil
excuse me i don't mean the yawn
oh
oh hi chair oh
okay i feel it's very scp
garden
i like gun
yes
well oh i reload
hey
where are you
go away
this is my flashlight apparently
can't see past my gun explosion why am i
walking around here with an m1 garand
what
[Music]
oh hi hi oh hey
what are these zombie nazis i've seen
many of those before
stop it stop it
okay
i have unlimited ammo
i'm ready for you
come at me [ __ ]
oh no you don't oh no you don't
whoa hey ah
i've got bullets for days baby
you think you could run now
i saw you there
hey
god damn you
okay okay okay okay
okay all right
stop it god they just jump up to you how
am i supposed to do anything if they
just jump up
i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready
i'm ready firing into the darkness
[Music]
stop it
oh a choice eh
all right
my choice is a hailstorm of bullets
how's that for a choice
i didn't do that
i literally didn't do that i know how it
seems like i did that because i was just
like randomly shooting i didn't do that
it just turned and shut
i didn't even see it before it shot at
it
her spooky
i didn't do that
what the hell
i legitimately did not do that my finger
was off
hi
hello
someone is sleeping here plant the gun
on them oh oh
not really much of a choice here is it
well uh good luck with that i'm gonna go
i got places to be
i can't lose you well maybe you
shouldn't have shot them i will bring
you back
[Music]
seems like your plan didn't go
so well wait a minute hello
oh
i always wanted to tell you how that
night really ended but i couldn't
because you were gone
i need your forgiveness that's why i
wanted you back at any cost
but in the end i robbed you both of life
and on life
please go on
and be with monica i'm sorry
[Music]
well
that's all quite very sad but maybe you
shouldn't have been rampaging through
your house with an m1 garand
[Music]
the facility level laughs in 35
seconds okay all right well i shouldn't
have waited around to hear the end of
that hi how are you doing okay um
this seems like a good place for the
escape tram
but uh
that didn't go so good
oh there's no okay escape trap it is i
thought it wasn't gonna go so good for
me before
oh
hi i remember you oh god
can i please oh my god oh wait
oh i'm sorry oh i'm sorry i gotta go
i got i gotta go train luke go to bed
start the yes
oh i'm not gonna make it go faster
oh
i don't know why this would end up very
differently for me than last time but uh
here i go i guess
what
oh
well that can't be good i don't seem
good
uh
oh
with the hell seal broken the spears
trap within the mansion can now go on
and with the hell gate shut the tears
that seep through begin to fade away
spooky has moved on and rests with her
parents now somehow despite all the
horror within the mansion
you brought peace to it all
[Music]
i did it
i did it i did it
hell yeah
spooky
all done
that's so nice
that really was cool i liked that a lot
that was fun
i didn't even think that it would be
like an end of the story here
oh pretty cool
the clown
what was up with the clown
[Music]
oh
that's very sweet
[Music]
oh that's very nice
that was great
i really liked that i didn't even expect
this to be a finality of the story but
it's good that it all comes around so
many things get left on like
an open-ended thing it's nice to have
something with like really rounds out
the edges so thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to see the rest
of my playthrough of spooky sausage
jumpscares before it was known as
spooky's jumpscare mansion check out the
link in the description below or go to
my channel and search for the playlist
called spooky's house of jumpscares or
spooky's jumpscare mansion whatever it's
called and thank you everybody so much
for watching lots of cool stuff in this
game i'm really glad that they came
around and played it or uh finished it
up so thank you let me know what you
thought down in the comments below let
me know if you solved that puzzle and as
always and we'll see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you